[Music]
the Weger activist ill ham Totti will be
awarded the 2019 Sakharov Prize for
freedom of thought accused of being a
separatist he's currently serving a life
sentence in China mep x' recognized his
work building bridges between han
chinese and weaker muslims and are
calling for his release his daughter
will accept the award on his behalf
MEP s will discuss the outcome of the
latest European Council summit climate
changed the --use long-term budget and
brexit were on the agenda the new
European Council President Shar Michelle
will be reporting back to Parliament for
the first time Parliament will elect a
new EU Ombudsman for a five-year term
the Ombudsman investigates allegations
of maladministration by EU institutions
bodies and agencies following complaints
by EU citizens or on their own
initiative MEP s will debate the state
of the rule of law in Malta after
sending a fact-finding mission to the
country the delegation was investigating
allegations of state corruption
following the assassination of the
journalist Daphne coruña Galicia the
Lisbon Treaty came into force ten years
ago on the 1st of December 2009 the
treaty gave more powers to Parliament
putting it on an equal footing with the
council in the EU s decision making
process
[Music]